Spotlight on Brazil: Spain team profile.
Defending champion Spain will be the team to beat in Brazil...
...as they attempt to make history...
...by becoming the first European nation to win the World Cup on South American soil.
The Spaniards have already become the first European side...
...to win three consecutive major tournaments...
...and haven't conceded a goal in ten knockout matches,...
...stretching back to the 2006 World Cup.
In qualifying, they soar off the challenge of France to claim top spot in their group...
...and will be severely tested from their very first game in Brazil,...
...having been drawn to face 2010 runners-up the Netherlands.
Fortunately, they have a formidable squad, including Barcelona's Andres Iniesta,...
...while Boss Vicente del Bosque...
...is the only manager to win the World Cup, Euros and Champions League.